things happening incredibly quickly
stewart
the r d
jonathan as the uh helicopters are
filling the sky around me apaches
blackhawks
chinooks
they're flying all over the place very
low at times some was just passing
overhead yeah it has moved extremely
quickly we knew that the taliban were
very near but they're now in town um
they came in we were told originally in
from all sorts of different directions
we know that there had been or at least
we believe there have been advanced
parties uh for some time but now they're
coming up uh coming in in larger numbers
a few moments before we came on air
there was gunfire from behind me there
had been gunfire earlier in the day that
we're not sure what that incident was
but this would suggest to me that it's
the taliban but it was relatively brief
uh immediately afterwards we saw the
apaches appear above us they're just
over here
to both my left and my right but
interestingly with this you know air
power is really important you can you
can control a huge amount of ground but
once they're in the city like they are
you can't just start bombing and
shooting indiscriminately because
obviously there are thousands upon
thousands of people who are living here
and thousands upon thousands of people
who are out on the street it's been a
relatively chaotic morning as you might
imagine the roads are absolutely
jam-packed
one of the reasons for that is that the
police who run the the roundabouts and
the checkpoints that are here have been
pretty much abandoned uh the green zone
which is where the diplomatic staff and
foreigners widely live which are gated
and guarded communities apparently the
guards have gone and the gates are open
and there is as you say this mad
scramble to the airport for the
foreigners for the diplomatic staff for
ngos and also for afghans who work
closely uh with the international
community who are very fearful for their
lives rightly so
so
what's going to happen in the next few
hours is is difficult to know as i said
they're really near to where we are
which is downtown the presidential
palace all right it's probably about
half a kilometer away from where i am
standing and i'm sure this is the
direction uh that they will be coming
and we know that qatar has indicated
that it's going to be peaceful and that
they've told their men not to fight but
i don't know how much control the if you
like the diplomatic side of the taliban
uh have over their fighting uh staff if
you like and um i don't think they have
much control at all so it
this could be a very volatile uh
situation add into all of this we've got
this um evacuation process we know the
it's very likely that the commercial
airlines are just going to have to stop
flying unless they can get assurances
for the taliban that the airfield's not
going to be attacked
there is a working assumption
particularly that from the raf that that
isn't going to be you know
it's untrustworthy so a lot of this lift
will have to be done by the raf and we
understand that air assets are being
brought in from all over the world to
move thousands of people uh a staff
obviously about 3 000 brits at least
that number of afghans as well and that
is completely dwarfed by uh the
americans who you know we're there to
some say tens of thousands of people who
need to leave all of this operation was
starting and was going you know
initially it was going to take uh you
know to the end of the month
um but now we're down trying to do it in
i suspect a matter of a couple of days
if
they can get an agreement with the
taliban that people are allowed to leave
and this operation
is able to run smoothly but as i say if
we're looking at british and american
helicopters up in the air
these are gunships then it would suggest
that they are looking to perhaps engage
with the taliban and then those who are
already in the city will engage as well
so this could go in all sorts of
different directions it's very very very
tense it has been for the last few days
to be honest uh but as you could have
imagined uh today it is it's gone to a
new level